a lone tanker just offshore from the
Zawiya
oil refinery waiting for a shipment of
crude oil that may not come for some
time Zaria is 40 kilometers west of the
capital Tripoli and is the second
largest of Libya's six refineries forces
loyal to warlord Khalifa Haftar have
blockaded the other five oil ports and
closed a pipeline servings are weir it's
gone from handling 300,000 barrels of
oil a day to zero it's proving an
effective weapon leaving Libya's oil
industry on the verge of collapse it's
something the Libyan government cannot
solve by itself I think the government
of Turkey the Government of Russia the
European Union the United States come to
realization that they stand by us and
they stand against this military
dictator who wants to control Libya
production is slump from 1.3 million
barrels a day to less than 70,000 and
it's costing 77 million dollars a day in
lost revenue and the country has been
forced to declare force majeure and
avoid a legal obligation to comply with
international contracts some sources
believe that Khalifa Haftar
may have agreed at the Berlin conference
two measures aimed at ending the oil
blockade but no details have been given
nor a timeframe nor what he may want in
return and every day without a
resolution pushes Libya closer towards
an economic crisis the warlord controls
two-thirds of the country with
well-resourced fighters who've been
battling to take the capital Tripoli
since last April Libya is already
suffering shortages of basic necessities
such as gas for domestic use even though
it is a producer the oil squeeze will
only make matters worse it's going to
affect everyone we rely on oil to give
us foreign currency without it there
will be a huge problem because Libyans
depend a hundred percent on imports from
abroad so without oil revenue prices
will rise oil is Libya's only real
industry but it has failed to match the
production levels seen join the era of
Muammar Gaddafi it was overthrown in the
revolution of 2000 and
the country should be as rich as Gulf
countries and untapped gas and oil
fields have a potential to produce 2.4
million barrels a day but it has
suffered from chronic mismanagement and
corruption so we have to show some
transparency we have to show some
reorganization and we can adjust you
know deny these allegations and stop
because the world cannot really a lie
completely with one side fuel is heavily
subsidized in Libya costing around four
US cents a litre unless the blockade is
ended that subsidy is likely to end and
prices are predicted to increase
significantly and that will only add to
the suffering of the Libyan people
Tony Berkley al-jazeera Zawiya Libya